sabías que el estómago humano puede
almacenar hasta 4 litros de alimento en
cualquier momento eso es casi como
cuatro botellas de leche que loco en
este vídeo vamos a ver cómo nuestro
estómago nos ayuda a procesar los
alimentos que acaba de recibir de la
cavidad oral y del esófago entonces por
qué no echamos un vistazo al estómago lo
acercaré para que podamos hablar
exclusivamente sobre lo que el estómago
está haciendo el estómago es el
principal responsable de tres pasos en
primer lugar va a recibir un bolo de
comida del esófago que está arriba este
bolo es sólo comida convertida en una
esfera que ahora se puede procesar así
que el estómago puede hacer dos cosas
para ayudar a procesar aún más la comida
lo primero que hace el estómago es
mezclar este bolo o mezclar la comida
las paredes musculares del estómago
permiten que esta comida se comprima y
se desintegre aún más también hay un
cierto grado de hidrólisis o
descomposición de este bolo asistido por
enzimas y en un momento hablaremos sobre
la enzima que es responsable de este
proceso
y finalmente después de hacer todas
estas cosas recibimos un producto que se
llama quimo el quimbo es una mezcla de
aquello en lo que se ha descompuesto el
bolo las enzimas gástricas y los jugos
que hemos usado la comida se va a quedar
aquí por un poco de tiempo porque el
estómago también almacena comida
almacenará la comida hasta que sea el
momento apropiado para verter el quimo
en el duodeno o la primera parte del
intestino delgado en el que se procesará
y es por eso que podemos almacenar de 2
a 4 litros de comida en cualquier
momento ahora qué pasa aquí con la
anatomía del estómago cómo liberamos las
enzimas y descomponemos este bolo
echemos un vistazo a la anatomía
gástrica justo aquí y veamos cómo es
responsable de la descomposición de los
alimentos podemos imaginar que el
estómago tiene todos estos pliegues
estas infecciones de la pared gástrica
que ayudan a aumentar la superficie y al
hacerlo hay una capa de células que
están por aquí esta capa de células
secreta gran cantidad de los componentes
del jugo gástrico que vamos a ver y
tiene muchos componentes importantes
lo más importante que debemos recordar
del estómago es que hay tres tipos de
células involucradas el primer tipo del
que voy a hablar son las llamadas
células parietales células parietales y
lo más importante que se libera de las
células parietales es el ácido
clorhídrico el ácido clorhídrico es muy
corrosivo en realidad es más ácido que
el ácido de las baterías además de las
células parietales también tenemos
células principales estas células
secretan una enzima llamada pepsi no gen
o esta es la forma inactiva de la enzima
el pepsi no gen o no está activo de
hecho para que se produzca la hidrólisis
necesitamos una enzima que se llama
pepsina cómo se hace la pepsina bueno
vamos a necesitar pepsi no g no para
hacerla pero el pepsi no g no y cada vez
que ves que no al final del nombre
significa que ya casi está allí sólo
necesita ser procesado para convertir el
pepsi no gene pepsina necesitamos ácido
clorhídrico que descompone esta proteína
para convertirla en esta formativa que
luego puede usarse para
hidrólisis ahora qué pasaría si
tuviéramos mucha piscina o mucho ácido
clorhídrico presente en el estómago todo
el tiempo que creen que le pasaría el
estómago probablemente se comería vivo a
sí mismo no es así quiero decir la
membrana celular definitivamente tiene
considerables cantidades de proteína que
debería estar allí presente y además
tiene esta sustancia ácida realmente
corrosiva que puede comerse al estómago
y así es como salen las úlceras
gástricas pero no todos tenemos úlceras
gástricas que tenemos adicionalmente
nuestros pozos gástricos que nos ayuda a
prevenir las úlceras gástricas para que
no ocurran en primer lugar bueno el
tercer tipo de células que tenemos aquí
son células mucosas tal como su nombre
lo indica las células mucosas liberan
musina y este es un recubrimiento que
está alrededor del estómago para
asegurar que cosas como la pepsina y el
ácido clorhídrico no degrade en el
estómago sin células mucosas nos
comeríamos vivos como revisión las tres
cosas que un estómago hará por nosotros
que mezclará con sus paredes musculosas
para ayudar a descomponer el bolo en una
actividad muy física además aquí ocurre
un proceso enzimático o químico en el
que usamos pepsina para degradar los
alimentos ahora la pepsina sólo degrada
un tipo de nutriente y es la proteína
romperá los enlaces peptídicos o el
enlace que conecta a los aminoácidos
entre sí para degradar sus
macromoléculas de proteína de modo que
ese es el único tipo de nutriente que se
descompone en el estómago
una vez que realizamos una cantidad
significativa de la proteína se va a
producir el quimo que se almacena en el
estómago hasta el momento adecuado para
que se lance a la siguiente parte del
tracto gastrointestinal que se llama
duodeno y es la primera parte del
intestino delgado y así es como funciona
el estómago